As we get deeper in to the Java plugin,
it'll be useful to know where
to get more information.
The first place to go is the Java quick
start guide, and the Gradle user guide.
You can find the link in
the instructor notes.
It has a quick rundown of
the capabilities of the Java plugin.
And if you need a refresher for
setting up a Java project in the future,
this would be a great place to go.
For deeper information
on the Java plugin,
check out the chapter in
the Gradle user guide.
Here you'll find the information,
all the tasks the Gradle Java
plugin defines.
There's also a great graph of
the dependencies between the tasks.
You can also get details on the default
settings, like project layout and
how to change them.